good morning David we went to the 2019
US Open Championships of table tennis a
few weeks ago in Fort Worth Texas to
catch up of one of the sports legends
who's trying to make one final run to
solidify his place in the sports history
the airbending serves the deep volleys
and the overhead smash this is table
tennis at the highest level a flurry of
action all on a nine foot by five foot
table an Olympic caliber athlete in peak
form is usually under age 30 Dancy
Miller is nowhere near that age he's old
enough to be an Olympians grandfather
all right steady nice but I learned the
hard way age is just a number for the 65
year old see Miller see Miller is a stud
in American table tennis he turned pro
at 18 and became the number one ranked
American player his triumphs were
featured twice in Sports Illustrated and
he shocked the world in 1977 when he
teamed up with his brother Rick and
defeated the number one ranked Chinese
team he coached to men's u.s. national
teams at the 2000 and 2004 Olympics he's
been in the USA Table Tennis Hall of
Fame since 1995
are you the LeBron James of American
table tennis well I don't know why as a
kid when I was training you know I used
to I want you to think that when I'm
done I want to be known as the greatest
American player ever you think you are
well that's not for me to say but my
resume is pretty strong instead of
retiring he's looking to add one more
highlight to his resume Olympic athlete
at the 2020 Summer Games in Tokyo the
road to Tokyo begins in New Carlisle
Indiana every morning starts with the
workout
he's eating right and getting back into
playing shape when he's not working on
his game he's a world-class coach yes
sir hosting clinics and running a
competitive Table Tennis Club his
friends and fans have set up a GoFundMe
page because training
full-time is expensive there are travel
costs tournament fees even the coach
needs a coat my grip is different from
95% of the players play shake hands so
they play with red sucker on the floor
hand with the finger out and thumb on
the top take that the lefty has a secret
weapon he plays with an old-school grip
on the paddle that could give him the
upper hand on the competition my grip is
unique because I'm using the forehand
red side and when I go over I flip and
still use the red side it's known in
table tennis as the CE Miller grip and
yes he invented it and perfected it
decades ago but no one uses it anymore
so he's banking on it to surprise his
opponents at the US Open he played well
leading opponents more than 40 years
younger than him like 22 year-old Devin
de Lyon to be able to play against such
a legend especially in the United States
table tennis is a great honor and I
don't feel any shame of being beat by
somebody so good
that serve he's God is crazy and now I'm
65 and I'm training really hard and I
don't know where it's gonna go but and
my wife says she says she knows I can do
it so who knows you're not just doing it
for yourself
you know nice for everybody it's also to
let anyone that's older you know that if
you if you really concentrate on your
techniques and you believe in yourself
you can do great in any sport
see Miller is so good here is his 1992
table tennis trading card he's on a card
that's how good he is is for his Olympic
dreams there is one spot left on the US
men's Olympic team but he has to earn it
he's not gonna walk on there and that
tournament is in late February in
California and he says he's gonna go
wishing him the best of luck has an
American ever won gold an American has
never even meddled at all and he's his
grip has fallen out of use but everybody
knew what it is and so now these younger
players are seeing it and they're going
what is what is it it's I can't it's a
windshield wiper is how he described it
and he absolutely embarrassed me on
national TV with hoping to do that again
on the world you're a good sport
we're all rooting for him
you